i'm pleased to say that we found the
cliff richard yeah and he's joining us
now hello to cliff
hi there how are you
i am great and uh joanna's here with us
uh johanna lumley of course and she is
your biggest fan joella
well she's she should be here because
she's a national treasure
that's exactly right you are the
nationalist nationally treasurer you are
the treasure beyond treasures
that's true oh my god that's true tell
me what role you're gonna wish your role
i'm on the i'm on the 50s bus
okay tell me i was about to ask you
cliff tell me more about your role in
the pageant today
well there's really no role i mean i'm
joining a bunch of people who in fact
started i guess their careers in the 50s
and the only thing that's really great
about it is of course that we share the
decade that the queen was crowned in and
so therefore i think it's special to be
there i'm thinking of jumping on all the
buses because i mean like
people like me have been around as much
as she has
and we're all getting so much older that
we've got to make the best of it
you first performed for her majesty i
think i'm writing saying in 1962
at the royal variety performance what do
you remember about it
what i remember is that it wasn't just
me though i had been in a show called oh
boy
and that started in about 59 or
something like that
and um
and that that particular year they
wanted a section of that show so i was
just one along with marty wilde and
billy fury and a few other people and i
remembered it it was much easier doing
it with other people though funnily
enough later when i got invited to be on
the royal as i loved it the royal
command
programs i still i'd like to like that
word command coming from the royal box
but um they were it was a little more
nerve-wracking but you have to go on and
stand by yourself
and uh it was take over the years i've
learned that you
it it's necessary to be nervous but you
have to get over that nervous post the
moment very quickly if you can
but i always loved it i think it's still
one of the most
well the feeling of honored
doesn't cover it it's just fantastic
when the queen wants to see you actually
you never really know we never really
knew whether the queen organized it or
whether
somebody else did but whatever it was
you sang for the queen and i've never
lost the feeling that this is a great
great privilege
and you did that in 2012 i remember it
very well at the golden jubilee do you
remember that moment
i do yes it was terrific the one thing i
will say now that the show that i saw
last night was probably the best
produced show ever done for the queen i
mean they must have spent millions on
the lighting it was just fantastic and i
found myself feeling slightly envious
that i hadn't been invited to sing
because i loved just one picture in
front of the palace lit like that but it
wasn't to be and of course i think that
and it's a good idea for instance i've
always been there and shirley bassey's
been there and tom jones and mccartney
and all that and i think the new
generation
needed to be there last night and
hopefully they'll be around to sing for
charles and then after that sing for
william so in a way those of us who have
done the years
um it's time to relinquish our positions
to a certain extent although i'm still
recording so i'm still going to be
competing with people in the charts but
i say
the new blood was good to see there
and i'd love to have been invited just
to sing a note just to be in that
production it was absolutely brilliantly
produced
it was superb and i thought the creative
and lighting directors both deserve
honors you've received one from the
queen tell us what happened when you
were knighted what did she say to you
what what first worried me was that
they'd said to me there's going to be a
sort of stool there and he said you
don't sit on it and it's got a handle
and he said
i suggest you kneel one kneel
one knee on it and hold on to the handle
he said i've seen grown men collapse
with nerves and of course it was
nerve-wracking but i did what they said
and the other thing was they said say
nothing unless her majesty says
something to you
so i got my hold of the handle and i
kneeled and the only thing i felt
worried about was when the queen came to
me she had the sword like this no
it was just fantastic she dumped me on
the shoulders i i was told then to stand
up and i did and i waited and she said
oh this has been a long time coming
and
i burbled
i mean i couldn't talk the emotion my
three sisters were there
the band started playing congratulations
and i i
was like this afterwards i said to my
sisters the queen's probably sitting
there with a cup of tea thinking why
didn't we give this night to someone who
could speak english
it was just nerve-wracking and it didn't
do too well at the end of it
i must share with you cliff that um
joanna used to mimic uh your with it
with a you tell the story you tell a
story you tell it much better cliff i i
know i know you've seen me do this
before and it's so shaming but anyway at
school when i was 12 because i'm only a
nats younger than you and you had living
doll and we were at a conference school
and we were fairly sort of locked in but
through radio luxembourg we could hear
the music and so i learned living doll
and i used to get my tennis racquet and
uh and just go got myself a crying talk
and sleep sleeping walking living dull
and everywhere oh god you're just like
cliff and i felt so proud
that is fantastic that's the best
imitation of me i've ever heard
do you think that you two could maybe
sing it together how do you feel about
that so closely actually i can tell you
something even better i was at wimbledon
one of those wash out that great washout
when nobody knew what to do because we
were all sitting in our seats and it was
just pouring pouring with rain and
suddenly you got up and started to sing
and you i think it was
we're all going on a summer holiday or
something like that you began to sing
and people were so thrilled and so
grateful and i was there to see you
well if you're right i started with
summer holiday but i was never meant to
sing
i had to said but if it was raining i
was asked to go and talk to wimbledon
radio
where they had they were interviewing
tennis players and things and they said
would you come and talk so i said yeah
of course i will and it rained so they
called me in suddenly i had this piece
of paper shoved just beneath my chin i
looked down now this was my first year
as a member of wimbledon and i looked
and it said the secretary wants to see
you in his office
so i thought i've got my badge on i've
got everything my name is there
my wearing my tie
anyway i went and he said look it's been
raining so hard and so long can you do
something for us and i said oh i don't
have a guitar here or anything and then
he said well what about if you did an
interview
i said yeah i i quite like doing
interviews yeah let's do the interview
so somebody came from the bbc and they
talked to me we did about 15 minutes or
10 minutes of chat and at the end of it
he said well ladies and gentlemen i want
to say thanks to sir cliff and i'm sure
you'll never forgive me if i didn't ask
him to sing something
and so it was a real shock to me
anyway it was pouring with rain so i
thought this is it the brits
are not bothered about rain they'll
still go for their summer holidays so i
went into we're all going on a summer
holiday and of course in the end i did
about 20 minutes and to be honest with
you they couldn't get me off i loved it
joanna you know what that feeling is
when you think you're doing really well
you want to stay there
and so cliff when will we hear you
because you're still recording are you
what's the plan are you touring
yes i am recording and i think i can
tell you
uh that um
the album will be out at christmas
amazing
amazing we're so looking forward to it
how much are you looking forward to the
day i i know i've got to let you go but
what are you most looking forward to
for the day today
what am i going to do what sorry
no i was just asking you sir cliff if
you could just indulge us and tell us
what you're most looking forward to
today
i think i'm looking forward and hoping
to find people waving up at me it's
going to be very difficult for all these
people to find their various favorites
because when you know what the
the bus is full of really people that
i've grown up with as well and and loved
and watched and played with so uh it's
going to be
wonderful if i've got a fan or two
that's going to wave directly at me but
anyway i think we're all going to we're
all ready to wave all these people who
have given us lives when you think about
it you know i i sometimes wake up in the
homes i have i have two homes and i
think myself how the heck did i get here
and uh so we have to show our gratitude
i suppose and this is one it's a great
time to show gratitude not only to the
queen but also to a massive public that
support all of us actors dancers singers
everybody so i'm looking forward to just
being
with a whole bunch of fans and other
people's fans too
amazing well enjoy the day thank you for
taking the time to allow us to be part
of it thank you sir cliff
my pleasure thank you